The audacity.
Women are done teaching men how to participate in adult relationships.
And that is extremely evident
based on what's been going on in the dating world.
Because now, when women are treated badly or not considered
or treated with disrespect,
we no longer look internally and say,
oh, maybe it's me,
I can fix him. No,
we realize there's something deficient in this man.
Because a good partner,
a good man doesn't have to be taught these things.
And I've been in relationships before
where I've had to beg men to show up in the way that I wanted them to,
and they will not hear you.
It doesn't matter how much you try to teach a man like this
how to be respectful, how to be considerate,
how to show up, how to have empathy,
how to actually like your partner,
they will not do it. Women shouldn't have to settle for partners
that they have to baby their way into being an adult.
Women don't wanna be your moms.
Women are done participating in relationships
where they have to do 100% of the emotional labor.
It's no longer desirable for women to do that.
And they don't really have to anymore.
Not like they really did before.
But honestly, the world convinced them
that men should be expected to do the bare minimum,
and we should be grateful for it.
Not anymore, bro.
Like, do the personal work yourself.
Go to therapy, read some books.
Because Men who know how to do these things are out there.
I didn't have to teach my husband how to be a good husband.
Women don't have the energy for that shit.
We have bigger battles right now.